oui bon c'est un très joli coup mais sur
le fond je ne vous comprends pas vous
êtes député vous représenter les
français vous dit c'est pas pour faire
du business mais si vous avez dit texto
la drogue va créer des emplois et des
recettes fiscales
mais vous renoncez à la lutte vous
renoncez à la lutte contre le cannabis
risque de dépression produits toxiques
mesure la cua répondu versé à m
mais c'est tout l'inversé tout d'abord
c'est un monopole d'état donc déjà c'est
pas du business comme tout le reste
d'ailleurs certains me critique là
dessus pour ce que vous dites
aujourd'hui c'est un million de
personnes tous les jours sa vie millions
qui sont face à des produits extrêmement
toxique puisque ils sont frelaté il sera
au niveau de thc
enfin grâce à l'argent de la fiscalité
nous aurons des moyens pour beaucoup
plus de prévention
de toute façon vous savez j'ai travaillé
avec énormément de policiers énormément
de médecins énormément de spécialistes
avec des experts des autres pays du
monde et il n'y a plus aucun pays au
monde censée qu'ils soient dans la
prohibition
donc ce geste permet ce soir d'expliquer
que la légalisation elle va arriver un
jour et je pense même dans deux trois
ans malgré les propos de de nombreux
candidats à la présidentielle ça sera
légalisée parce que quand vous aurez
l'espagne l'italie la suisse la suisse
le luxembourg la belgique l'allemagne
qui ont légalisé ou à peu près qu'est ce
que vous ferez en france une politique
qui n'existera pas c'est l'un des jalons
aura députés et des magasins de cbd
partie sort du cannabis on va dans les
bureaux de tabac ya quand même les
feuilles avec l'ific enfin toute
l'industrie est là tout le monde est
prêt il ya juste à légaliser qu'il un
seigneur mais qu'est ce qu'on va voir
mais si vous regrettez votre geste ou
pas ce que je veux surtout dire tout ce
qui regarde et je sais que vous avez
beaucoup beaucoup de jeunes le cannabis
en dessous de 25 ans c'est dangereux
je n'ai pas un geste doit inciter à la
consommation c'est un geste justement
pour inciter à la précaution à la
prévention
ne touchez pas au cannabis surtout si
vous êtes jeune et si vous êtes usager
soyez extrêmement prudents avec